foreign
title of my talk is structural Pathways
of cancer cellular Networks
why doesn't it so how does a cell
respond to environmental cues
who respond
signalsely to be relayed from the
extracellular space to the nucleus
I'm sorry from the extracellular space
through the cytoplasm to the nucleus and
back so what happens is that signaling
molecules bind to the extracellular
domain of membrane spanning receptor
these are at the top right hand side of
the diagram then they pass through the
membrane through the cytoplasm and then
through physical interactions between
the proteins in the cell
and the proteins that relay the signal
make up a signaling pathway
along the way each protein May modify
the pathway the signal Pathways May
integrate as we see at the bottom left
hand side panel they made crosstalk as
we see on the right hand side diagram
they can Branch as we see on the right
hand side panel and get Amplified
and to figure out how signals propagate
in the cell we need at the very least
the structural network of the signaling
Pathways and the protein and pathway
Dynamics
and this can be very nicely seen in the
yeast protein protein interaction
Network which has over 1500 proteins and
over 2300 interruptions
looking at this map
it is immediately obvious that a huge
effort has been invested in constructing
it it is also obvious the
pains an enormous amount of info
information
yet when we look at it we still do not
understand we do not understand how the
signals propagate we do not understand
how the cell functions under
physiological condition and what happens
in disease we don't understand how
oncogenic mutations alter the network or
alter the signal and we do not
understand how the proteins and the
proton function question
a noun is a protein an edge a protein
protein interaction
some proteins have a small number of
interactions other proteins the
so-called hot proteins can have a very
large number of interactions which can
be in the tense and even in the hundreds
and even if this protein is a very large
multi-domain ones they still do not have
physically
sufficient surface area exposed to have
distinct binding sites so to understand
how the proton functions to understand
signaling androphysiological conditions
and in disease and to understand this at
the signaling Dynamics under varied
conditions we need to have structures
and we need to be able to predict what
is the preferred way for proteins to
interact
so what is the preferred way for
proteins to interact an ultimate goal is
to predict the preferred mode of protein
associations
we know
similar protein structures can associate
in different ways and different protein
structures can associate in similar ways
so what is the preferred way for
proteins to interact
currently there are two major strategies
the first is looking a definition of the
docking problem given to
two proteins structures predictor native
interactions
joking is difficult because there are
many possible favorable ways for protein
to interval proteins to interact and in
the absence of additional biochemical
data it is very difficult to distinguish
between the native interaction and the
other interactions there will always be
patches of hydrophobic surface areas
hydrogen bonds salt Bridges Etc
Doki becomes much more difficult if we
don't even know if the proteins interact
second way is knowledge based using
protein protein interaction databases
form the basis for making Pathways and
the basis for a more complete picture of
the organization of the cell and within
this a protein protein interface data
set is particularly useful
this is because the number of motifs in
single chain proteins and as we have
shown over the years in protein protein
interfaces is limited in nature
consequently a protein protein interface
data set is useful for predicting
protein protein interactions for the
construction of interaction networks and
for large-scale protein docking but
particularly when combined with
refinement and energy scoring which is
what we have been doing
proteins interact through their surfaces
so here we have a timer with three
chains with two interfaces
our definition of an interface is as
consisting of residues within which are
in contact across the two chains here we
see for one interface they are improper
for the other they are in grade and
residues which are nearby the residues
which are in contact for one interface
they are in cyan for the other they are
ingredient
interfaces do not consist of continuous
fragments consequently there is no
sequential border so in interface
consists of single residues and bits and
pieces of the chain which are in contact
or nearby the
store chain we can see this in the panel
on the left hand side the boxed region
is the interface and on the right hand
side we can see this we see that the
interface consists of residues 33 to 41
60 to 61 63 to 67 153 72 to 83 and so
forth now in order to construct a
non-redundant data set of protein
protein interfaces we need to compare
all interfaces in our database with each
other
if they enter if the race if the
interfaces consists of contigo's
references then it's straight a
relatively straightforward because we
know how to superimpose the two
interfaces if they don't then in
principle what we need to do is to try
and damage every patch of surface of one
reason of one in of one interface with
every page of surface here of another in
all rotations and all translations which
in practice it's an impossibility
and here we can see this suppose on the
left hand side we have one interface and
on the right hand side we have another
suppose each circle depicts the
coordinates of a c Alpha atom as we can
see in space
a corresponds to a b to b c to C D to D
and E and E twitch however on the left
hand side the protein chain connectivity
goes a b c d e on the right hand side it
goes a b e c and d so so finding this
spatial similarity without a sequential
order is very difficult
and here I always like to take a little
bit of time off to explain
how the apparent difference between the
fields and yet how interdisciplinarity
and collaboration Across The Field's
help
when I was faced with this uh with this
problem I met High moves on uh who since
then has become a long time collaborator
at Cape on the campus of Tel Aviv
University
Hein spent many years in the Israeli
Army and he was then focusing on his
expertise in his in computer vision and
Robotics and I asked him what are you
doing these days and he was just telling
me he said well imaginos
that you have a series of aerial
photographs and you wanted to detect an
unpredefined pattern in this area
photographs when they repair with
so-called errors for example consider a
tank but the tank can appear in this
area photographs with some occlusion for
example by other vehicles meetings trees
Etc but you still want to be able to
detect that you have the same object
recurring in their aerial photographs
when I heard this I got very excited I
literally jumped because it was
immediately apparent that despite the
seemingly very different fields not the
least the problems that we were facing
are quite similar
I'm set Aryan photographs correspond to
our series of pdb files his pixels in
there
pictures or in the images are our Atomic
coordinates his errors or occlusion
refers to other correlates with others
means with hours mismatches insertions
and deletions
Etc he was looking for
similarity of the or detection of
patterns of points in three-dimensional
space which is exactly what we need to
do in order to compare our interfaces
together then we started this
collaboration addressing this problem
and adapted his computer vision based
algorithm which is called geometric
caching to our problem
how does it work then to generate the
data set of non-redundant protein
protein interfaces we start with the PDP
which is the protein structure database
we consider all molecules monomers
dimers trimers
we then Mark all two chain interfaces
here now shown in
board with an extract extract them
we then carry out and all against all
structural comparisons of these
leading to their clustering
using the geometric hashing algorithm of
course leading to the clustering and
then we pick a representative from each
of the Clusters
this representative then forms our
non-redundant data set of protein
when we then looked at our clusters we
realized that we have three types of
clusters
the first type is less interesting in
the sense this is expected we have
clusters with similar interfaces that's
not surprising after all weak Mastered
by the interface structures
the global structures of the chains are
similar and the functions of similar
types two and three are much more
interesting okay in type to we have
clusters with similar interfaces however
the global structures of the chains are
different and the functions are
different here if you compare in the
second panel in the middle you can see
that the orange on both sides looks
different and the green looks
we have interface clusters with only one
similar side the complementary side is
somewhat different
in type 2 we have a situation where we
have similar interfaces and different
functions
function type 2
wheeler to monomer structures where
Evolution has utilized good favorable
motifs for many different functions so
of all the combinatorial possible ways
for different monomer structures of the
proteins right to associate they still
prefer to interact in similar ways to be
preferred interface architectures and I
don't have time to show you but these
in preferred interfaces the structures
of these preferred interfaces are the
same ones which are preferred in single
chain proteins
examples interface clusters with similar
interfaces here boxed
see on both sides you see that on the
inside in yellow we can see similarity
structures and but this similar Global
faults of the proteins compare the pink
for example chain on the left hand side
with the grain of cyan on the right hand
side and these similar functions
another example similar interfaces again
boxed dissimilar Global structures of
the chains again compare the pink with
the green either the top or the bottom
and the similar functions
finally the last example similar
interfaces dissimilar Global structures
and dissimilar functions here for
example one on the bottom we can say one
is equivalent main from the scaffolding
scaffolding protein and the other is a
red fluorescent protein
so the point
s similar interfaces and different
Global structures allows the prediction
of protein interactions of course
signaling Pathways and the protocol
so how do we go about the prediction
suppose the circles on the top contain
each one contains a Representatives
interface we then take the left hand
side of the interface or one side of the
interface and carry out a structural
comparison with the entire surfaces of
all the monomers in our pdb
then we take the complementary side of
the interface and again carry out a
structural comparison with the entire
surfaces of all the monomers in the pdb
then we predict that those proteins that
have a patch of surface similar to the
left hand side of the interface can
interact with proteins which have a
patch of surface which is similar to the
right hand side of the body of the
interface similarly we do this for the
next representative
one side of the interface carry out
structural comparison with entire
surfaces
of all the monomers in the pdb then the
right hand side and compare with the
entire surfaces and then again predict
that those proteins which have a page of
surface similar to one side can interact
with those which have a page of surface
similar to the other side and those
great circles that you see are the
residue hot spots which contribute the
significantly to the stability of the
interaction and so on and so forth we do
this for all the cluster for all the
representatives in our data set
so the prediction algorithm we start
with a representative essay template it
all the monomers in the pdb are targets
we take one side of the interface
suppose we take the surface on a and
carry out a comprehensive structural
comparison with the entire surfaces of
all the monomers in the PDP
you can see there suppose we find
that the surface on a is similar to the
surface on if
then we take the complementary side the
surface on B and carry out the
structural comparison with entire
surfaces of all the monomers in the pdb
suppose we find that the surface on B is
similar to the surface on E on G and on
D so then we can predict
that F can bind can interact with B with
d with G and with e even though
Global structures of
b d g and e can be totally different
from each other
okay
we filter we find we score we Rank and
check against experimental databases
to predict the output
I don't know what that is
Okay so
so
coming back then to the question that we
asked at the beginning of the talk so
how can the prediction of the preferred
way for proteins to interact help in
understanding cellular power
a
presentation as we can see on this
screen
which is typical and one can see this in
many networks in talks in papers
in books is difficult to understand what
we can see is that the product in P1
here at the center in the Box can
interact with before P3 P1 and P2
however we have no idea which of these
interactions can take place at the same
time and which cannot
however if we translate this
representation into a structural
representation we're choosing the
strategy that I have just described we
can do then we can see that what the
input one can interact with P2 before
MP6 it is cannot interact with P2 before
and B6 at the same time since they
interact through the same b11 interface
however protein P3 can interact with P1
at the same time as B6 or before or P2
since they interact through distinct
interface
oh how
and to try to understand this so the
binding can be at the same shared side
however the site can be slightly
different with minor or major
conformational changes depending on
earlier allosteric event and that decide
may decide in addition to concentration
post-translational modification
Etc with which protein the a given
protein will interact at any given time
and this concept can be applied to the
modeling of protein protein interactions
in Pathways across the protein
applications to key cellular Pathways
that we have carried out so far include
ubiquitination the regulation of protein
degradation can cause overexpression and
cancer
apoptosis this function can deregulate
cell survival versus death to make K
pathway again relates as we know to
signaling and cancer
interleukin-1 relates to inflammation
and cancer I think inflammation and
cancer the mass protein which we are now
working on over 20 percent of human
rights of human cancers have oncogenic
mutation syndromestic genes the Twilight
receptor again inflammation related to
cancer and the nuclear hormone receptor
particularly we have been focusing on
the global corticoid receptor and to
some extent on the minimum receptor
here is an apoptosis pathway map and
which illustrates the point that I've
been trying to make about the critical
importance of having structures and the
way in which the proteins interact in
the past
this apoptosis pathway map which is
redrone following the kid the keg stands
for the Kyoto Encyclopedia of genes and
genomes and there are many such diagrams
in the if you just look in the internet
again in papers books talks Etc there
are absolutely no structures what we can
see are proteins
we see this as ellipsoids here and the
edges the lines which imply interactions
looking at this we cannot understand if
we cannot understand how the pathway is
actually regulated
if however the proteins have structures
and we know that they interact we can
predict how they interact is for example
we have done here and in this way we can
do this for all proteins that have
structures and are known to interact and
we have done this here
next what we can do is to take all
proteins and try to predict if they
interact even even if we do not know the
danger for example there are no ages
connected them and we have done this as
well and when we did this we could see
the IAP the inhibitor of thetosis
positive feedback loop which was not
available before
is to the aisle one signaling pathway we
have assembled the pathway from related
from related Pathways and literature
there are approximately 80 interruptions
between proteins with known structures
only 16 or 20 in structures of protein
protein complexes and the structures of
the complexes provide interface residues
with possible diseases
seen by mapping this sleeps and
mutational data snip with the nucleotide
polymorphism single nucleotide
polymorphism
so here we have the i1 signaling pathway
and that we have constructed with the
structural data
proteins which do not have structures in
the pdb white
the rest which are
Cactus the arrows which are shown in
wall
AI that there are the structures of the
complexes in the PDP those which are in
thin lines with those which are
connected in thin lines imply that we
predicted structures if we you see
dashed line it implies that we have only
one the structure of our new one side of
the interface
here is it one example of a
have constructed and I'm going to show
you only this particular example of this
particular of this particular three
proteins
so here is the complex ity predicted for
the neck okay four and make K3
my K4 is in brown or gold make A3 is in
blue where is it just which you see in
bones are in the interface if they are
in brown they belong to the mega K in
into the mega K protein if they are in
blue they belong to the make K3 protein
residues which are in yellow are the hot
spots residues belonging to make
and those which are in Cyan are hot spot
residues again hot spots contribute
significantly to the stability of the
complex are belong our hotspot residues
belonging to make K3
the red residues
one of these that we can see is the
asparaging 234 in the top
the mutation of asparagin 234 to
isolusin
has been related to ovarian to ovarian
serous carcinoma as we can see this
particular residue sits right in the
interface as does serine 251
the mutation of serine 251 to asparagine
again has been associated with
metastatic melanoma
another example here make for we June K2
with the same coloring scheme here again
we can see the Searing 251 whose
mutation to asparaging is related to
metastatic melanoma seating right in the
in the interface and the last example
here make a four we June K3 here we see
the Arginine 154
whose mutation to trip has been to
tryptophan it has been related to
colorectal adenocarcinoma which is the
most common type of colon cancer and the
gland one the glutamine 142 mutation to
leucine also in the interface has been
associated with lung cancer we saw it
with long squamous cell carcinoma
so next what we have done is to try and
understand the mechanism of the
mutations in order to do this we
evaluated the stability of the complex
in the case of the wild type and the
mutations
most of the time the mutations
destabilize the complex
what it means is that the protein does
not need The Binding of its partner in
order to turn it on the mutation already
can already do this which then turns the
protein on constitutively
for the repressor proteins it acts
opposite way
see the interaction with a similar
outcome
here we look at the toll like receptor
pathway in inflammation which we also
have been interested in and by now has
been have been have worked part of it we
have been we have worked out
here are some of the interactions
related to the pathway the modern
interactions of Mighty 88
what we can see is here is in the center
that the mighty 88 has two domains the
death domain on the top and the tier
domain in the bottom the we have the
crystal structures of these and they are
connected by some Linker here you see it
is this line because there is no
structure for the Linker it's highly
flexible
looking at the death domain and
predicting its interaction
through the Scion
interface the cyan books leading to the
NF Kappa B
inflammatory pathway however that same
binding site can overlap with the
interaction of my d88 with the food
protein and interaction of the mighty 88
with the fight leads to the apoptosis
Pathway to opposing Pathways with
opposing functions with remote which
remarkably or interestingly share the
same interface they suggest that my d88
signals either through the iron full
pathway that's to say either
inflammation or apoptosis similarly we
can see on the top 1988 withdraw 6 the
interaction at the same site we have my
d88 retract three again trough 3 and
draft six these are two opposing leading
lead to opposing opposing Pathways with
opposed functions and at the bottom the
same principle the tier domain of the
myd88 which interacts with the tier
domain of the toe like receptor idea for
in this case that we have looked at and
the that interaction by the 88 and Mal
interact with the tier domain of the
toilet receptor however if this
interaction competes with the
interaction of geometries
here we can see such competing
interactions in this case my d88
interacting with Iraq 4 and fed and we
can see they cannot take place at the
same time because we will have steric
hindrance steric loss
here another example in this case for
the air
the kinase
so what we can see is that the Eric can
interact with make one and pla2 at the
same time
ever make one okay at the bottom cannot
interact with mp1 and next the same time
sometimes a shared binding site on Mac
one
similarly though not exactly the same
situation we have here where we see that
the air cannot interact with PTP and
Risk 2 at the same time not because they
share an interface but because there is
a steric clash between these two
proteins if they were to interact at the
same time with
here is the rust pathway map which is
again another another pathway that we
are now extremely interested in and are
actively working on there are no the the
pathway is
is largely not understood and weakens
what we have is proteins we have the
structures of some of the proteins and
we can see the pathway diagrams again
with links however we do not understand
what happens there are different eyes of
us has different isoforms which prefer
to Signal through different Pathways can
we understand this from here or with our
different ontogenic mutations again they
prefer to Signal through different
Pathways without detailed structural
data we cannot understand
and here we can see this by looking at
some statistics here the rust isoform
mutations in human cancer
so Russ has three major isoforms keriwas
neras and atras and that chaos has two
subheads two isoforms keros for a and
k1's 4B keros is particularly
looking at the numbers we can see that
Keras has a 95 percent incidence in
pancreatic cancer 45 incidence in
colorectal cancer 35 in lung
adenocarcinoma
we have no idea we do not understand
why keros is so prevalent in these
particular cancers as compared to the
errors
which is more common in AML or melanoma
and atras which is uh more common not
very common but still more common in
bladder cancer we do not understand
these numbers
so the Keras alleles have distinct
biology and we do not understand why
keros g12v and g12c
have worse clinical outcome then g20d we
have no idea why so here we have the g12
glycine 12 which can be mutated to
either valine or cysteine and these I
have the worst clinical outcome as
compared to the mutation of the same
glycine wave to aspartic acid keros g12d
has elevated pi3k and map signaling as
compared to the others we have no idea
why
keros g12c and g12 V has elevated Royal
GDs signaling and other effect rules all
of these effectors appeared in there was
diagram that I have shown you before and
we again do not understand why from
looking at that diagram and the Keras
G13 in response to this particular drug
however g12 mutant student
so it looks like mutations of the same
residue leads to altered signaling
through those Pathways that we have seen
before but the map could not explain
this
so the questions that we ask is can such
questions be tackled by detailed
structural data we believe so
here are the chaos limitations in three
diseases in colorectal lung pancreas and
again we can see if you look at the line
of the color or for example the
colorectal cancer you see the large
variability in the incidence for g12c
versus g20d versus g12v for SSG 13d we
don't understand his numbers and
similarly we do not understand them look
at the lung cancer we have 22 000 uh I
mean cases for the g12c versus
1190 for the g13d we do not understand
why
why so mechanistic questions on the
molecular level in chaos biology that we
have been asking include does rust is
ordered hyper variable region or hvr for
short at the C terminal has a role
Beyond membrane anchoring
does rust time rise and if so which is
what we believe why and in particular
how
what are Ross redundant Pathways what
are the mechanisms of rust oncogenic
mutations and call modulin where does it
bind and how does it inhibit transactive
rough's activation and more we are
interested in all of these questions and
we are addressing all but in my talk
today I'm going to relate only to the
first
so it's been well established at the
foreign hvr anchors in the membrane
paper unexpectedly we found that the hvr
of K was 4B which has been taught to
minimally impact the catalytic domain
directly interacts with high Affinity
with the active site of GDP bound but
not cheaply bound Keras for me
the question is that hvr also have an
overlooked regulatory wall which is what
it seemed to us
our collaborator nadiatorosova
in the in also in the concerned
inflammation program at the NCI in
Frederick has carried out a number of
biophysical experiments among these is
the microscale thermophysis which shows
that the hvr peptide interacts better
with the GTP than with the GTP bound
keros will be but still we would like to
understand where and how does the keros
for BHB are preferentially bind because
if we have the structure then we may be
able to better understand the reason and
the mechanism
I'm a collaborator in Chicago
has carried out any more chemical shift
perturbation experiments for the GDP
band keros for B and the GTP boundary
as one can see we have an ensemble of
states which is not surprising the hvr
at the C terminal is highly flexible
it's highly positively charged so it's
expected
where and how and how does the care was
to be our preferentially bind
we then model than sample of States
simulated following the hbr data and
what we have observed is and you can see
this in the circled region that the the
hvr can adopt a better strength
conformation which is which is selected
by the better sheet of the rust protein
at the active site so the hvr kit beta
strength can then extend the better
strength in the
in the effect one binding equation this
is where the some most of them some of
the effectors find this is for the GDP
bound kerosphate and this is as one can
see at the bottom in agreement with the
NMR data and with Nadia's biophysical
experiment
the other hand for the GTP bound chaos
for me we see only loose interaction of
the of the hvr we see this at the bottom
this blue segment again in agreement
with NMR data and with Nadia tarasova
hvr rules extend beyond membrane
and include prevention of premature
signaling of Keras for bgdp a function
that was overlooked earlier
in in earlier chaos 4B signaling models
and the auto inhibition
sets a threshold signaling control and
The hvr Binding interferes with rust
rough Interruption slows down nucleotide
exchange and inhibits our signaling into
more sales and for
importantly significantly the hvr's auto
inhibition identifies a newer struggle
so why are we interested in
so why are we interested in structural
structural Pathways predict new
interactions not observed in classical
Pathways in particular in scaffolding
protein they they allow identification
of redundant Pathways in drug resistant
mutants they may discover positive
feedback altering core processes as we
did in the case of Inhibitors of
apoptosis or the IRB protein they
provide interaction details they allow
identification of oncogenic mutations as
I have shown you
for their mind one pathway they help
drug Discovery they allow us as multi
subunit signaling complexes as I've
shown you for example for the mighty 88
the ksr and interactions that cannot
coexist just like I've shown you for the
Eric mp1 make 2 and the Eric bdp and rsk
and simulations provide insight into the
mechanism and they allow verification
so why is insight into the mechanism of
single proteins imported
they they make this helps in relating
oncogenic neutral mutations to their
constitutive concept to them I'm sorry
to their constitutive consequences
weather activation
the mechanism helping understanding the
simulations I should say help in
understanding the mechanism of drug
resistant buildings and they have been
Wrong by testing the stability of their
interactions and the care what is it we
are currently studying relate to growth
migration and geogenesis Invasion and
metastasis of cancer cells including
Ross where where we are addressing
activation and binding kinases
particularly we are interested in the
egfr and the rough spot in and pi3k
ligands and the bcl2 apoptosis anymore
here just to give AF a short overview a
brief I should say overview of the
mechanisms of oncogenic mutations how
they work and here with the example
taken for this from the kinases so the
oncogenic mutations can bypass Auto
inhibition through three mechanism
on the left hand side we see on the top
left hand side we see a free energy
description
with the
of the proteins of if the in the active
and inactive states where we can see
that on their right hand on them sorry
on the left hand side what we can see
I'm sorry I have to put my glasses on to
see on the left hand side we see that we
have the active State on the right if
you look at the red curve we see that it
has a lower minimum as compared to the
left hand side that means that I'm sorry
in the egg the native state is in the in
green whereas the Newton state is in the
red so in the left hand side we see that
under normal circumstances physiological
circumstances we see that the left hand
side of the green has a lower Minima
than the right hand side which implies
that the inactive state is more stable
on the other hand when we have a
mutation what happens is that the active
State on the right and this is in red
lowers the meaning so now the
conformation shifts to the right hand
side and this we can see in the figure
just under it where we can see that we
have this particular mutation of the
teeth
this particular mutation there which is
marked which stabilizes the hydrophobic
regulatory spine of the active state
in the middle we can see mutations in
the middle of the free energy landscape
on the you know the top left hand side
we can see that mutations can also
destabilize the inactive state which
would have the same outcome the active
state would have a lower minimum than
the inactive State and we see the
situation on the right hand side at the
bottom where the mutation this stability
disrupts the hydrophobic core of the
inactive State and on the right hand
side at the top we can see that the
mutation that mutations can work through
both mechanisms
destabilize the inactive State and
stabilize the active State and this we
can see at the bottom of the right hand
side panel or the mutations both
stabilize the alpha Helix in without the
light without light and induced receptor
diversity station
here are some overview of the mechanisms
of allosteric limitations I'm not going
to go into it we don't have time and
finally they
they
major bottom line of the talk that
computational structural biology can
help experiment by providing more
complete information and needs a
complete map of Key cellular Pathways
with structural data including
multimolecular associations of
scaffolding proteins
is good
it's pretty understand cancer cell
biology with the abnormality originating
from their regulation of signal
I should close by thanking my colleagues
at the NCI here
in Tel Aviv University hi Wilson and our
great students Max noid
Alexander in Hungary my great
collaborator Peter shermanly and as to
the Russ the collaboration with Carla
Matos from Northeastern University she's
a crystallographer and with Nadia
tarasova at the NCR and University of
Illinois I describe this work and the
head and next kwamos circus Sonoma
people where we collaborate on the tlr
and the inflammation and cancer Pathways
with the CIP the cancer and inflammation
program and with that I shall thank you
very much and I shall only show a
beautiful image
which was drawn by Peter ceremy's friend
who is an artist and it appeared on the
cover showing how drugs can work in the
network and these are allosteric drugs
so the drug here targets the protein at
the bottom the blue one
diseased in
the instant one at the top in pink but
through the network and through the
interactions the allosteric effect
should go even though this figure is not
exactly right it's an artist rendering
in reality the proteins should have
interacted physical interactions here
they don't but still it conveys the
spirit so thank you very much
if I don't know is there any uh if any
questions
since there are no questions
maybe I should just thank the audience
for listening and uh
I guess we can get off the air
okay